good afternoon everybody Welcome to
NASA's Johnson Space Center I'm Dan
Hewitt and I am joined today by crew 5
recently returned back to planet Earth
just to my left we have jax astronaut
koichiwakata recently wrapping up more
than 500 Days career in space NASA
astronauts Josh cassida and Nicole Mann
and all the way on the end there Rose
Cosmos causes but not Anna kikuna they
are excited to answer your questions
we're going to be taking them from
reporters on the phone bridge and from
social media if you're on the phone
bridge press star one to get into the
queue and since we're doing this
virtually please let us know who you're
asking your question to and if you're on
social media head over to Twitter and
use the hashtag asknasa and we'll get to
as many as we can today so we are going
to jump right in to questions so off and
running we're going to start off on our
phone Bridge let's go first to Marvin
Marshall with the nighttime news Marvin
nothing yet okay I'm going to
sounds like we just lost our phone line
so I'm going to start off while we get
that reconnected uh this one for I'll
start with koichi you've written back
now in multiple different spacecraft how
did dragon compare to some of your other
re-entries back home to Earth
each and every spacecraft has its own
uniqueness and I really enjoyed this
fully almost fully automated aspect of
the spacecraft and it's a really a
smooth ride up and down and uh one of
the the you know different things that I
saw on the spacecraft the dragon is
during the re-entry I was able to see
the uh the plasma of the during the
atmosphere entry so we had like a fire
work and then with the glow of the air
for a long time so I was able to enjoy
the light show during the entry was
really impressive and then for my three
first time Flyers what's I mean what's
that one thing that really stands out in
your mind that you took away from
spending you were up there 157 days with
maybe one day that if anyone asks you
what did you do up there what do you
remember what's the first thing that
pops into your mind Josh we'll start
with you
uh boy that is a tough one to narrow it
down uh to one
um but I think the top two that uh that
immediately come to mind uh one was late
in the mission uh I thought I was up
earlier than everybody else and I went
to go use the restroom and it turns out
I was at least second because Duke was
down in the cupola
um and I heard her down there she called
me down and uh we saw the most
incredible Aurora
um it was absolutely breathtaking we
just went in there and I'm sorry it
seemed a little selfish but we just
absorbed it we didn't have the have the
skill set yet we hadn't consulted with
kuichi about getting some photography
done uh in that setting but we just kind
of hung out in there and it was just so
powerful we did get some great shots the
next day but I really think that first
day was uh just uh just breathtaking
um and then in terms of uh professional
satisfaction for me it was uh our second
spacewalk for me and Frank when we went
out the door when we came back in it was
just this this overwhelming feeling of
everybody had done their job uh Duke had
just done such an amazing job getting us
out the door uh koichi flying me around
and putting me where I needed to be to
get the job done uh the teams on the
ground uh just absolutely Flawless
execution
um and we only could do it because
everybody did their job incredibly well
and that I wasn't expecting that kind of
emotional reaction the nice thing is
Tears Don't run down your cheeks in
space so I we just called it allergies
when I was in the airlock and we had
gotten the work done and our flight
directors Scoville got on the loops and
uh kind of put it all in perspective so
those are the two big ones that pop out
for me all right Nicole those were two
big ones I totally agree and it's it's
tough to choose I think one thing that
was interesting for me is towards the
end of the mission I went back and I
read my journal from the beginning of
the mission like that first week and it
was so cool to to remind myself of that
perspective that I had those first
couple days in space that first time
floating around in zero g and and uh and
seeing everybody it's something that I
don't think you take for granted but you
get used to you get used to looking out
the window and seeing our beautiful
planet you get used to just floating
around and tossing an m m you know to
your friends uh when you're eating and
so it was fun to to kind of go back and
reflect on what that feeling was like in
the very beginning and then when crew
six arrived it was cool to see it
through their eyes for that first time
you know when you get out there and
you're floating around and you're kind
of unsure and you're and you're unsteady
and to see how quickly they crew six was
adapting to see how quickly they were
picking up on you know all the
maintenance tasks and all the daily
tasks that we were covering during
Handover you can see that that journey
in yourself and in your crewmates how
much you change during that time and how
you adapt and it was uh really uh nice I
think just to take a moment and to
appreciate that and have that
perspective
all right now Anna favorite memory
uh
yep
nakuma
well I will start with the first thing
that really impressed and surprised me
when I got onto the Isis right when I
flew through the vestibule is that it's
really real it exists here it is
and the second thing is when we got to
the Russian segment and I saw everything
I realized that it matches perfectly all
of our mock-ups and of all of our
simulators and it was really comforting
and reassuring because it was like I was
seeing something that I heard already
knew something that was familiar
robot
and then the next thing we just had to
practice so the Handover was very smooth
the previous crew really told us how to
do everything explain the ropes showed
us everything and then we just had to
dive into it and begin doing it and we
did it and we did it well and it was a
really smooth transition and from
morning till evening every minute of the
day was planned out for us there was a
whole lot to do including both servicing
the station and Performing all of the
experiments
all right thank you crew five now we're
going to see if we've bastard this whole
phone technology we're going to give it
one more shot let's start with Marvin
Marshall with the nighttime news Marvin
awesome thank you very much Dan can you
guys hear me gotcha gotcha loud and
clear awesome sounds good oh good
afternoon I'm Marv Marshall from the
nighttime news at space report on Twitch
TV
um this is my my question is for uh all
of you guys here uh could each of you
share a hilarious moment
hilarious moment that's uh
every moment was a hilarious moment but
uh for me I was I found out those guys
are really you know test pilots and
Engineers but they are really good at
the cooking in zero gravity and uh you
know when we are having some holidays uh
uh you know Josh was really good at
cutting the cheese for pizza and Nicole
was making adobo with all the uh the
dried meat and stuff like that and Anya
is a really great cook of Olivia salad
and I was really good at eating all of
them but I was really impressed with
their technique of all the zero g
cooking so that was a very hilarious
moment that I experienced
uh the moment that I remember uh we
laughed really hard when we're up there
uh one of the ones that uh sticks in my
mind
um the uh ng-18 the Northrop Grumman
cargo vehicle that came up has hundreds
if not thousands of these gold
carabiners uh that are used to uh to
Stage the the cargo and they're super
useful so we end up using them on the
station for our own purposes
um and there was a day uh you remember
when Frank was working in node one
um and he had a kind of frustrating task
that he was working on and uh the ground
was had a camera looking over his
shoulder which he loves uh to have more
Cooks in the kitchen and
um what happened was one of the one of
the carabiners had gotten away and he
was dealing with something else and it
is not a big deal we can we can go find
that uh but they alerted him to the fact
that he had lost a carabiner and that
was not what he wanted to deal with at
that moment so I took it upon myself
about 10 minutes later just to sit in
the lab and I took a gold Carabiner and
I just sent it his Direction at about
you know three centimeters a second and
he just continues to work and somehow he
had just moved his head enough that it
grazed the back of his hair but he
didn't feel it and the ground lost their
mind again and started yelling and he's
looking around and I'm laughing so hard
because he has no idea where it came
from
um and so I was the only one who knew
where it was so I grabbed it and I
showed the uh showed the ground that I
had I had solved their problem and uh
Frank was over two and he couldn't
explain to them that I was just messing
with him
that was kind of a recurring theme Josh
medicine but um we were in space we did
laugh a lot it's hard to choose just one
but I do remember one time we were
getting ready our suits ready for our
Eva for kuichi and I uh to get ready to
go out the door and I had sized the suit
and I put my boots in and I have small
feet relative to the size of the Emu uh
feet and so I have these inserts that go
inside there but I wasn't able to push
it in very good with my hand so I was
like okay I need to just get my foot in
there to push
um this insert all the way into the boot
because you want it to fit properly you
don't want to deal with it day of so I'd
say hey this is my plan I'm just gonna
you know put the uh the lower torso on
push my feet in so everything fits fine
you know Josh says hey you need help
you're good I was like Oh no I got it
like I'm totally good okay he floats
away so I'm in the airlock I get the
lower torso on I get my feet in I get it
all situated hey everything's feeling
good perfect and then I go
oh like it's really hard to get out of
that lower torso and you don't have
anything to push against them we're
usually never getting out of the suit by
herself so I realized very quickly I'm
stuck in my pants and um Josh has
already floated away I don't see Frank
I'm like oh man what am I going to do so
I poke out koichi's way down other end
of the lab down into a koichi koichi you
know I'm yelling at a slide on station
he looks like I'm stuck in my pants and
I don't know if I you know I'm speaking
quickly or maybe his you know primary
language is Japanese but he's like what
now crazy I'm stuck in my pants I need
your help and so unfortunately he helped
me get out of my pants so thanks
um
[Music]
Isabella
Anya
I had a funny situation when I went to
space I brought the symbol of my city
it's this little doll actually I brought
three of them and the first one I took
immediately with me to station and the
other two I left in the vehicle for a
little bit
foreign
and so I went back to the soyuz to get
the other two and I wanted to have them
and they weren't there and I looked
everywhere I looked in all of my things
I looked around my crew quarter I looked
and looked and looked and I came back
several times throughout the duration of
the mission and I just couldn't find
them anywhere and mentally I said
farewell to them
yes and finally uh
spot
okay
[Music]
and then it was time to go home and so
we got back into the vehicle
we undocked got ready to sleep
pulled out our sleeping bag sleeping
bags and there they were there they were
my two little dolls they were sleeping
the whole increment they slept through
it all
well I found them and I brought them
back home with me
I'm glad you tracked them down all right
next up on the phone we got Bill Harwood
with CBS News bill
for every crew crew Dragon Landing can
can two of you maybe describe the
sensations after five months in
weightlessness or six months uh when you
hit the water
and the things even in a gentle swell is
that disorienting for you that's number
one what's that like getting back on the
boat and number two just can can you
talk a little bit about uh what's been a
surprise about your re-adaptation to
gravity I mean astronauts have been
doing this for quite a while cosmonauts
but has it gotten any better does it
still take about a month to get your
legs back and and not be disoriented
just how's all that going thanks
we're at what four days right now do we
share the secret with them sure go ahead
gravity is not cool
after being in zero g you come back to
gravity and you're thinking this is
going to be great it is not great
it takes you a while to to adapt uh you
know we have trainers that help us you
know with their strength and their
balance but I think we're four days into
it we're still a little bit
um a little bit wobbly
um but I think um to your first question
coming downhill really really The
Landing wasn't that significant
um but feeling G for the first time so
when we start re-entry we have a g meter
we could see the G rise and uh we all
commented okay well here we are we're at
half a g it's starting to rise and like
half a g holy smokes it felt like
somebody was sitting on your chest and
pushing you down you only had half a g
and so by the time we were at 4.5 G's
you're really getting smooshed into that
seat you're really focusing on on just
breathing you can feel your tongue in
the back of your your throat and it's
just amazing because it's so powerful
and so strong
um even though you know that that's
going to be the profile it's still
amazing and then the drugs coming out
and the shoots coming out those were
those are pretty Dynamic events and
you're really swaying around so by the
time you get to splash down it just you
know you splash down
you are we had calm seas and light winds
but you get a little bit of a Dutch roll
kind of going on
um and so you can definitely definitely
feel that and it definitely made me feel
a little bit tumbly
uh for me you know Nicole's right the
G's are a little uh surprising I mean
even if you're ready for them
um but uh I took it upon myself to kind
of keep everybody aware what the G's
were as we were all doing our own
different tasks but just kind of let
them know where we are and where we're
headed and I remember calling out you
know four and a half G's or so and for
me it was really strange my inner ear
started doing its thing that it hadn't
done in almost a hockey season and so
um I noticed that I had to like lock
into the frame of the of the display and
my eyes kind of did this it was like the
Matrix it was like a glitch glitch in
The Matrix where uh I would tumble maybe
five degrees and then instantaneously
end back up and then tumble five degrees
and it just kept doing this like every
two to three seconds and uh that lasted
until we were back down to probably
about two and a half or so
um so thank goodness it wasn't permanent
um but uh I agree that you know it was
uh it felt to me it it felt very similar
to what you would experience it's in a
ride that was trying to simulate a
re-entry you know the sounds of the
vehicle I thought well that clearly
somebody's playing an audio Loop right
this isn't actually what it sounds like
but it does it sounds just like uh doing
a ride at a big amusement park at least
that's what it felt like to me
all right next up we're going to go to
Elizabeth Howell with space.com Liz
[Music]
I brought you to be the first Native
American woman in space and how uh while
you were up there you were trying to
talk to various groups to inspire the
Next Generation thanks
absolutely you know my journey I think
is is one that kind of evolved as I grew
and so I didn't have it all figured out
when I was young and I didn't know
um you know really what it meant to be
an astronaut who became an astronaut or
how that even
um was possible and so it wasn't until
later on in life that I really started
considering that career path and looking
at the different opportunities so I
think it's really important for all of
us astronauts to share our journey we
all have unique Journeys on how we
became an astronaut we have all unique
dreams and aspirations but the one thing
that we all share in common is that
we're very passionate about what our our
jobs were prior to becoming an astronaut
we're very passionate about the work
that we do on board the International
Space Station and so that communication
of our journey and our excitement and
our love for what we do I think is very
important to help Inspire the Next
Generation if a young child can look up
at you know the screen and see us
floating and see us sharing our stories
whether you come from Russia or Japan or
the North or or California wherever your
background is whatever your race your
religion anything you can you can share
in that joy and maybe you see something
in that astronaut that's sharing their
story uh something that you connect with
and maybe that's the one thing that will
help motivate a child to to reach for
those dreams maybe that's the one thing
that will give them that additional
discipline they need to not only
establish that dream but then go out and
be successful in conquering that Gene so
I think that's something that we all
share in common as very important
Nicole all right we're going to jump
over to a couple of questions from
social media real quick this first win
I'm going to give to koichi this comes
from awoo-woo I hope I pronounced that
right we've heard food taste different
once you're in space is your mind
flipped does food taste different once
you come back to earth
actually that's a really question uh as
far as I'm concerned I think uh you know
food did not taste differently in space
in zero gravity uh on my shoulder and
long fights and uh this time of course I
long for fresh food when I came back the
food in space space station is really
good but we really have fresh food like
salad and stuff and I was really longing
for sushi so I asked my wife to bring
Sushi to The Concourse when we get back
we got back to Houston and it was really
good so for the first time in five more
than five months I had sushi and it was
great and I wish in the very near future
we have something like that in zero
gravity in space station and I hope it's
happening
on the to-do list for the Food Lab uh
all right this next one I'm gonna give
to Anna this one's from Igor um since
returning to Earth have you dropped
anything on the grounds unconsciously
thinking that it that it should have
floated
um
foreign
yeah I had something similar happen I
came up to the table to grab a grape
from the table and imagine my surprise
when by grabbing one I ended up grabbing
a whole patch of grapes and then my hand
just fell onto the table instead of
gently lifting everything so then I had
to work my hand up and work the one
grape off the rest and only then I was
able to go free
[Music]
so this is from Roger he said he was
waving to you from the beach and wanted
to know if you could see him Roger I was
waving at you I don't know we our
windows are smaller so you might not
have seen me
so we did you know Queen she's right uh
the The View was incredible on the
re-entry of that plasma right that soup
of ions and doing its thing I actually
thought these colors I wasn't expecting
those I mean we saw pink we saw green we
saw blue
and at some point
um it was uh it was really something and
so Roger I'm not sure that I actually
did see you I tried I'm sorry I
and then I'm going to send this one to
Nicole what was the most challenging
aspect of living and working in space
five months and how do you overcome that
Velcro definitely velcro it's your best
friend and it's your worst friend all in
the same day I gotta be honest like
sometimes you just need velcro the good
velcro that works when you stick
something there it actually stays even
if it gets bumped a little bit and you
know all velcro's not created equal so
sometimes that velcro is very strong and
sticky
um when you need it to and then other
times you know in station there's areas
where it's a little bit older and so it
doesn't do as good of a job
and then there's the velcro Anya will
will appreciate this with me it grabs
your hair every time you float by so you
have your hair back and it's the strong
velcro especially in the airlock that
gets you and you'll be floating and it
will literally like stop you your
movement and you pull back and you're
like oh and yeah don't go so I know Josh
and koichi you don't think you had the
hair velcro situation but I know that
you realize the look on my face that I
just got velcroed and and I think we all
kind of shared that a little bit and the
station is a big place and so it
actually really helped me and quiche
keep track of where Nicole was so we
could actually just follow her path
um and then she'd be whimpering a little
bit at the end of that path but yeah we
uh we knew where you were where you had
been
all right we're going to take a couple
more from our phone line let's go to
Marcia Smith
with space policy online Marcia
oh thanks so much for taking my question
I'm curious for the three of you who
have been out on Space walks you know
you've had these two incidents now where
the soyuz and the progress might have
been hit by micro meteorites or space
debris or something when you go out on a
spacewalk and you look back at the space
station are you surprised to see how
many things there are in it and I mean
do you look at it and you say oh gosh
look at all that or is it like are you
alarmed if how many hits have been how
worrisome is it that there's so much
debris up there
yeah personally I was feeling lucky and
it worked out pretty well
um we do see some evidence when we're
out there and we are we are trained
extensively to uh to not let the
evidence you know that what's you know
sometimes these handrails can be uh have
Burrs on them and that's a real problem
if we were to cut our suit
um so yeah it definitely does happen
um I certainly didn't see anything
actively happen while I was out there
um we've got uh such an amazing system
and the people running the system uh
that if something like that should
happen
um more likely than not uh you know we
would be able to uh get ourselves back
to the to the airlock that the system is
is going to maintain uh the pressure uh
unless it's something catastrophic but
that isn't happening very often uh I
actually saw no evidence of that while I
was out there any any big holes so
um and we're trained uh on how to how to
deal with that we've got emergency
procedures just like flying in an
aircraft
um so you know I think in line with
everything else we do we plan for all
the worst situations and when those
don't happen it works out really well
and if it you know if we do have to fall
back on our training it's just becomes
second nature so I wasn't terribly
worried there's I think we're more
worried about messing something up while
we're out there uh than something uh
maybe the fairly low probability like
that
all right next up we have yusuke tonyama
with Yumi yomi Yuri shum boom yusuke go
ahead
um can I hear me yes we can hear you
okay uh thank you for taking my question
Japanese so my question is
you mark fifth space right on this group
by Mission it's the highest record among
Japanese astronauts let me ask you your
next goal so do you want to fly to the
space more how about your ambition
um thank you
okay that's a good question of course
space is my passion and as far as I can
fly I would like to you know keep flying
but you know
is flying uh um on the cruise 7 and I
would like to support his uh training
and then flight and also we have
selected new uh jaxa candidates
um so I would like to help support their
training and Mission and then utilizing
my uh experience of training and also
space flight so uh after that if there's
any chance of course I would like to be
involved in this any of the activities
in human space flight no matter where
the destination will be thank you
all right next up nikio tanabe with NHK
nikio
I thank you
for one of my question is from katason
so I'm just wondering what your emotion
was at the moment when the crew drop was
flushed down or when the hutch of the
crew Dragon was open you looked smiling
and took something with the grand stuff
what did you talk about
and I'd also like to ask about the
future what do you what do you want to
do after you return to Japan can you
tell us about your professional and
private life thank you
okay what do I want to do after I return
to Japan that's a good question I have
to think about I think I still have some
time yeah
yeah good sushi and then ramen noodles
especially in uh you know my uh time in
the Fukuoka I really have good the
memory of having good ramen there so I
really like to do that and beyond that
uh it's still I would like to think
about about the definitely I would like
to be involved in human space
exploration uh utilizing my experience
and uh I at the touchdown I really felt
you know what happened in the last five
months was really in a dream and uh it's
it's wonderful to to have accomplished
so many things with the great crew with
a real candle crew here and on both the
space station we have our crewmates on
board the station exhibition 68 crew we
have encountered actually a lot of
issues technical challenges that we
coped with all of these with the support
of the ground people and that's what
human space exploration is all about
with the great teamwork we will be able
to overcome the difficulties that we
face and we achieve so many things in
the utilization of the space station so
I hope that this cooperation collab
operation International collaboration
and also the commercial Partners
collaboration will continue to expand
our presence in the low earth orbit and
to the moon and Mars Beyond so I would
like to be involved in this human space
exploration no matter where I work and
that's my dream
thank you
all right looks like we're getting to a
couple of follow-ups now let's go again
to Marvin Marshall with nighttime space
news Marvin
hi thank you for taking another question
it's Marvin again here um now I'm
curious uh this is for you know Nicole
Joshua and whoever wants to chime in
here um how you know how is the sleeping
a poor dragon and where did you guys all
sleep uh did like you guys sleep above
the display where was your uh you know
sleeping positions and you know I just
want to apologize my last question got
cut off there um but you know I really
want to extend my heartfelt gratitude to
NASA for allowing me this opportunity
today and welcome back to the incredible
crew 5 astronaut thank you again
awesome thank you so much um sleeping a
dragon was was pretty comfortable I
think the um going up uphill so for
after launch we had about 29 hours in
Dragon before we docked a space station
we all slept in our seats and I think I
kind of you know I slept but I would
always wake up but every jet firing and
sometimes turn on a display uh just to
be aware of what was going on and it was
all such a new environment so
um it was a very light sleep I would say
and then um towards the end of the
mission once Cruise six came on board we
turn over our crew quarters to the new
crew and then we're all kind of in a
camp out state so we move and sleep in a
different location and I had the
privilege of sleeping in Dragon during
that time and that was really special
very unique
um opportunity for me so it was about a
week and I just slept in Dragon really
underneath the seats with one bungee to
keep me from floating around you don't
need the support of the seat or or
anything since you just floating in
space but the one thing that was really
a true treat is that you can wake up in
the morning take the window shade off
and drink your coffee and look out the
window and just marvel at our beautiful
planet watch the sunrise watch the
sunset that was very very unique and
then coming back home we uh I slept
underneath the seats again where I had
slept for the past week and everybody
else slept in their seats again I think
we all kind of sleep for a couple hours
and you know kind of wake up think about
where we're at what's going on could I
double check and then kind of go back to
sleep so I say in general it's
comfortable but your mind is not totally
at rest because you're about to you know
Return to the Planet so there's a lot
going on up there
I don't remember the part where Anya
woke up no that is that is a true
statement yes she's got some skills that
is incredible I'm jealous
all right next up let's go to Sophie
Sanchez with Cosmic Chicago Sophie
hi thank you for taking my question
um I wanted to talk to you guys about
veggie if I can get your um experiences
growing the plants on Earth
um sorry in space I know that for the
past veggie experiments it was more to
look at the tech demonstration that we
could grow how the tech and the habitats
for the plants worked but this time
around for veggie five you guys are
supposed to be looking at the
organoleptic assessment and reaction how
you guys interacted or felt growing the
plants can you guys share a little bit
about um your own organoleptic
assessments of growing plants in space
thank you
good yeah I had a privilege to work on
the veggie experiment and it's space
station inside that there's all like
machines and computers and it's really
rare to see you know living creatures
other than human beings so actually it's
really soothing to to to be able to
you know touch the living uh things like
plants so we grew tomatoes on the veggie
five mission and every day pretty much
every day we added water and checked the
condition of the uh the plant and it was
very soothing for me to be able to to
see that and unfortunately I didn't have
a chance to eat it but Frank and uh crew
members of screw six exhibition 68 to 69
will be able to harvest it and I really
Envy but I think this kind of plant
growing harvesting is a very important
thing for a long duration mission to to
Mars in the in the near future I hope so
I think we have been doing a excellent
experiments how to grow in the
Hydroponic and aeroponic manner of the
plants for future exploitation missions
and I was very fortunate to be able to
participate in that experiment
thank you koichi next up let's go again
to Elizabeth Howell space.com Liz
again this would be
this would be chime in can you just talk
about the significance of women's
history months and about the
contributions of diversity in making
space a fairly awesome place thank you
begin
of course uh so I think it's important
that we celebrate
um each type of unique event as I spoke
to you before it's really so that you
can kind of share that journey and help
Inspire the younger generation I think
the uh the diversity that we have in the
U.S astronaut Corps and in our
International astronaut and Cosmonaut
core is is really incredible it's a
great reflection of the diversity that
we have on planet Earth and that's so
important to recognize uh we're I think
getting to the point too where that is
not really as much news as it used to be
in the past right the the fact that a
woman was flying to a space or that a
woman was doing a spacewalk uh you know
fortunately we're we're finally
progressing I think enough to to an Era
where that's common nature you're going
to see with the Artemis Mission when we
go to the Moon you're going to see you
know women you're going to see people of
color you're going to see all different
types of people be a part of that
Artemis Mission and that is really
reflecting who we are as a human species
and that includes all of our
International Partners as well and so I
see this as a is a great thing to
celebrate of course we're not totally
there yet right there's still areas in
the world areas in the United States
where we have barriers and and we're
working to overcome those but it's great
to also celebrate the progress that
we've made where it is the the capable
and the certified that are selected uh
for a mission and to execute that
mission
foreign
[Music]
and there is this concept of the ying
and the ying and it is well known that
different teams groups Partnerships are
at their best when there's a
representation of the ying and the Ying
of the female and of the male teams are
more effective they are more successful
and they are more productive as groups
yes
and if we're talking about developing
Humanity in other planets and extra long
space travel to those other planets then
it makes all the more sense to prepare
both men and women males and females to
go to those planets to be ready to be
strong to be to have high levels of
endurance so that they are functioning
well when they reach those planets and
that's why it makes sense to have both
Representatives do space exploration
all right thank you Nicole and Anna we
got one more in the phone Bridge Marcia
Smith from space policy online again
Marcia
well thanks so much for taking a second
question uh mine is for Nicole you gave
that very entertaining story about your
spacesuit incident earlier today Axiom
rolled out their prototype of their
lunar space suit and Collins of course
is developing a new one for Leo
are you and the other astronauts
being brought into the discussions on
how to design these to make them easier
to use and what one piece of advice
would you give them
so in general yes NASA is being
consulted quite a bit on the development
of the new spacesuits and they're
looking at you know a wider range of of
body types that can fit into these
spacesuits and rightfully so because
we're all unique and we have different
heights and different widths and so it's
very important that we make a spacesuit
that is adaptable and so that you're
able to function and get the the job
done more effectively in a spacesuit
that can that fits you personally and
that is adaptable to fit a variety types
of people since we've been you know on
board the International Space Station
and just returning uh have not
personally been involved and
unfortunately I was in testing this
morning so I didn't get to see the
rollout of the new suit but I know we're
all very excited for that suit the the
Emu is a great suit but it is some
Antiquated technology and so I think
what we'll see with these next
generation spacesuits are not only the
ability to adapt to to different body
types but also the use of you know
computers or Imaging that gives you more
information to understand and easier to
use that spacesuit for for really
everybody and so this leap next leap in
a generation I think will make our
capabilities on Eva much more effective
all right and one more on the foam
Bridge Manuel mazante with the spacial
Manuel
of the crew I I'm curious to know
um how do you feel after Splashdown
because
you guys not only have to adapt again to
gravity after Splashdown but then you
have the capsule moving along with the
waves and you have to be like one hour
waiting until you are uh retrieved out
of the water so I wonder if that
does it make it even more difficult to
adapt or how do you guys feel during
that hour inside the the crude Dragon
thank you
well uh that last hour was the uh what
the 30th hour we'd essentially been
awake so we were pretty beat
um so uh that was kind of a a nice
little uh relaxing moment where we
didn't have to do anything
um so uh I would say that I was
expecting it to be a little bit more uh
benign in terms of uh of the Rolling
waves and I think they ended up being a
little bit bigger than we we had
expected
um but personally I felt fine I didn't I
didn't feel sick but uh you know I was
the first one to get moved out of the
Dragon
um apparently because I'm the biggest
one on the crew which just says we have
a small crew if I'm the biggest guy so
uh we have some incredible uh people uh
who are taking care of us uh most of
them are former PJs from the U.S Air
Force and so they came and moved me
first and I don't know if you guys saw
it but uh that was probably one of the
more exciting parts of the diorbit they
moved me pretty quickly
um and so uh that
um I moved they got me where I needed to
be because they're big and strong and
they got me right where I needed to be
and then when I went to get out
um still feeling good and the the
problem I had was my body really really
wanted to lean forward and uh it took a
couple other big guys to make sure I
didn't do that a little too much
um but uh that that hour I actually
enjoyed that it was a nice little calm
uh respite before we got back to uh to
real civilization
all right that's going to do it for our
foam Bridge got a couple more on social
before I let you guys free uh this first
one is from Dane for koichi uh where'd
you get your sushi once you got back to
NASA
actually I have to ask my wife okay
okay Dane may or may not work for NASA
so that's probably why that one came in
um and then for this one we're gonna
we'll close on this one but I'll ask
each of you so aside from you know
splashing down get in on the boat what's
the first thing you did once you kind of
got back and you had the freedom to do
whatever you want what's the first thing
you did
first thing in in the spacecraft tour no
so back back on Earth yeah so you
basically once you got back to Houston
you you had you had freedom to do
whatever you wanted to do what was the
first thing you did
I think I took a shower and enjoyed the
water droplets really dropping because I
have not seen that view for five months
it's kind of strange that the water
doesn't stay here but it drops and then
I really enjoy that
I ate my body weight in Cheetos
true statement I was going to share them
with my kids when I decided we'd do that
some other time it's impressive
but uh and then uh the first afternoon
that we had off we had a little bit of a
break I got to play catch with the boys
and that was super fun
um the weather broke a little bit and we
got to play catch so we joked before we
left like how were you playing cash were
you did you make it all the way to the
kids or where was your your toss a
little sort of messed up these guys
could verify I never got good at
throwing things in space which meant I
was still able to play all right that's
a skill
um for me it was that first hug with my
husband and my son you know he thought
about it and I you know it's gonna be
great to see them but the second I got
that hug I just held on for probably way
too long I don't know it was the
greatest feeling uh in the world just to
be connected with them in that way you
know of course we have pretty good
connection with phone calls and some you
know FaceTime type of of audio visual
calls but really that first hug was was
special and I'll always remember that
foreign
well if you ask me I imagined that when
I got to that the place of
Rehabilitation I would also enjoy that
shower and just to have all that water
on its own drain away from my hair but
actually it turned out that even more
than that I enjoyed just laying on my
side and not doing anything
all right well that's gonna do it for us
I want to thank everybody for calling in
and sending your questions on social
media to crew five welcome home it's
great to see your smiling faces back
here on planet Earth and it's been a
pleasure to work with you over the last
couple of months while you were in space
obviously their journey is done in space
but they've got a lot of work still to
do on Earth in fact Josh I don't know
where your sunglasses were I hope the
lights aren't too bright uh but you know
a lot still ahead for them but 157 days
in space they came home on Saturday
really great to have you guys appreciate
you coming and spending an afternoon
with us that is going to do it for us
continue to follow all of our space
flight action on nasa.gov and the
commercial crew missions to the
International Space Station a lot more
coming soon that'll do it though so
we'll say goodbye good afternoon and
farewell
[Music]
thank you thank you